what do you what has changed recently
like then one of the things a lot of
people have been saying with especially
the me to movements if people are more
cautious about saying controversial
jokes now do you feel that you feel like
energy in the air being different do you
feel like it's more sensitive I feel the
energy is different but guess what G
what it don't apply to me it don't apply
to me doesn't apply to me and it's never
gonna apply to me
okay I understand me shooting your
special on your network you don't want
me to use certain words there's parts
and I and I get that this is a business
right this is a business and I got
mouths to feed but when I'm at the
Comedy Store when I'm at The Improv when
I'm at the Laugh Factory when I'm in
flappers when I'm at the haha when I'm
at New York Gotham you got to let it fly
I'm gonna let it fly yeah I define okay
and I'm sorry
no you no no I'll be sorry you know just
so you know you know what I put on
yesterday which guess what I put on the
studio yes to what
and then this is it this is it because
it's time we're not taking it no more no
more I put on an album and again I'm
very sorry if I offend somebody I didn't
name it this he did so take your [ __ ]
problem up with him namely Alma's
bicentennial [ __ ] by James Richard
Richard Pryor I put it on I listened to
it twice later than edible and cry I got
a [ __ ] I've got the the periscope
listening to Richard okay I got it
yeah okay and I've listened to Lenny
Bruce live from Carnegie Hall in the
last couple weeks I don't know when the
last time you listen tonight because we
can't because of our we guys like you
and I can't definitely not Jamie and
definitely under 30 you can't because of
the cost lower this is how slow cultural
references how slow it is but it's a
lesson I listened to that and I'm gonna
go on home guess Roma's into tonight
what I'm staying in tonight listen to
the one when he meets the wino meets
Dracula oh I think it's either
is it something I said or the [ __ ]
crazy both of those albums are
masterpieces and that's how he wanted us
to do it yeah that was how we have to do
it yeah he didn't give a [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] was said now if a company wants to
pay you HBO or CBS and I am Joey can we
talk to in the corner we can't have that
jump because we got a complaint about
that I'm gonna dolt I can't sell you
know
listen Bill Hicks is dead no don't feel
too good myself okay all right let's cut
the [ __ ] [ __ ] okay we do this for
profit at the end of the [ __ ] day
we're feeding our families alright so
but there's also a way you do it and
there's also a compromise the way you do
it from your profit you know when I
watched the Richard Pryor thing and I
know he wanted to throw the Hollywood
ball and they were doing the thing for
gays and he went up there one against
the gays
I got it is it something I would do I
don't know I don't know but it's who was
supposed to be in a way as a comedian
was supposed to be the social column of
society in a way in some way so now you
want to take that away from me
you want to take the way I can't say I
grew up on the word [ __ ] I grew up
on the word [ __ ] I grew up on the word
I grew up on a lot of words that people
don't accept today and I'm very sorry
that you don't accept them but it's too
late for me to change my game right now
yeah I'll try my hardest I try my
hardest
I'm still gonna say [ __ ] from time to
time I know it offends but when you're a
comic listen man the first seven minutes
of to any news is about what's going on
in the world the next ten minutes is bad
I never talked about power at this
moment to top it off I'm a felon so I
need to talk about power you know I'm
taking my vote this is things I'm not
gonna talk about kicking an abortion
child number for a long time every comic
was you know I'll kicking aborted
freedom that's not my style
I'm updated talked about you know four
aborted yeah yeah you go to comedy shows
and there's always a technology shock
that wants to be shocking
to be shocked I mean I'm here to tell
you how I see it you want to get how I
see it
this is how I see if I offend you I
offend you too before in the beginning
of the show I said some very offensive
in today's terms but in my reality was
real you want firecrackers you buy them
from a Chinese dude charlie why is that
racist because that's racist but a face
is ready how's it real it's factual
Chinese people out of fireworks right
move please
there's weird ones that we all let fly
like black dudes at big dicks no one's
complaining about that right you ever
hear that you assume black dude has a
big dick because anybody complains
probably they look into now that might
be like maybe I'm the first one to get
called out on it that's racist to think
that black dudes have big dicks is it is
if it's positive is it pot is like a
positive attribute racist I'll give you
said Asian people are better at math
people would say that's racist how is it
racist if they're really good at
something like if they have more talent
or skill or more accomplishments how's
it racist but this isn't that racial if
it's good right like Jews accept it if
you tell Ari that more European Jews of
one Nobel science prizes he's like of
course we're smarter in court is it is
it racist to talk about how many Jews
are so [ __ ] smart like why is that
why they say about damn smart you think
about how many German and and European
Jews we're like [ __ ] serious geniuses
it's a it's a crazy trend like what
happened over there Kalin was try to
explain it to me once but their values
their education and experiences and what
led to just google the numbers of
European Jews that have won Nobel
science prizes it's kind of like it's
eye-opening you know how many guineas
from New Jersey zero zero guineas from
New Jersey when in science right none of
my relatives win in science project
looking us up a couple weeks ago it was
hard to look at
oh is it yeah what did European Jews
that have won the Nobel science prize
try that I don't know I don't even know
what these numbers I'm talking about in
my ass I know that it's I've definitely
heard it discussed that there was a
giant number
what do you doing over there Joey Diaz
Oh
fourth of July baby this is our our
country's birthday is a time that we
should cherish I think we should play
the national anthem maybe later
we gotta play the national anthem real
quick they have all this more than by my
house I loved it I [ __ ] loved it
so how was your experience doing your
Netflix special everything was great
Netflix I'd take my hat's off him
everything was great it was my [ __ ]
it was my [ __ ] I let it uh get into my
head too much I listened to too many
people when I forgot the number one
thing just be funny
that's it be yourself doesn't matter it
babe how many each shows did you film to
first of all I think was a disaster the
second one I redeemed myself a little
bit we'll put something together we'll
save something so now I'm working really
hard like now and now I'm going back to
my old roots how I wanted to I stand up
again it's hard